hello i'm katrina farrell public
information officer with the city of
henderson police department this
critical incident community briefing is
intended to provide you with information
about an officer-involved shooting that
occurred in the city of henderson on may
thirtieth twenty twenty two
this is the first officer-involved
shooting involving city of henderson
police officers in 2022. the city of
henderson police department is committed
to valuing and preserving human life the
protection and preservation of all human
life including the lives of individuals
taken into custody is the department's
fundamental objective and primary duty
of all henderson police department
employees you're about to hear pertinent
communications see relevant video
footage learn more about the evidence
and our response related to this
incident to better provide you an
understanding of what occurred based on
what is known to this point in the
investigation
the city of henderson police department
conducts very thorough use of force
investigations which typically requires
investigators to interview multiple
witnesses
view numerous hours of video footage and
analyze a significant amount of forensic
evidence
this transparent viewing is in no way
intended to draw any conclusions about
whether the officers involved acted
consistent with our policies and the law
until all the facts are known and the
investigation is complete
a word of caution the images you're
about to see may be disturbing and you
may hear strong language
when a police officer uses force to
arrest a subject or to defend against an
attack it can be graphic and difficult
to watch viewer discretion is strongly
advised
hello i am michael blow deputy chief of
the field operations bureau the
following is a brief overview of an
incident that began on may 30th 2022
around 7 a.m in the 100 block of
metropolitan drive henderson patrol
officers were dispatched to this
location after receiving reports of a
male who appeared to be breaking into
multiple vehicles on metropolitan the
subject was described as a very skinny
white male adult wearing a black and
yellow baggy shirt and carrying a bag of
empty shell casings here's the 9-1-1
call and corresponding radio traffic
henderson 9-1-1 what's the address of
the emergency
um it's a gentleman walking down
metropolitan i'm on
okay
he came and banged on my door
and asked for a ride i'm like i don't
even know you
but he's getting locked over to my
neighbor's house and uh
got a lot i tried to see if her car was
unlocked
okay
and he's walking black or hispanic
uh white very skinny now he's looking
through my other neighbors my other
neighbor's car down there he's wearing
what color shirt
it's a black it's like a chinese yellow
and black uh
baggy shirt he's carrying a bag of empty
shell casings too by the way
things like guns yeah they're all over
there they're even all over my driveway
if you're intoxicated or on drugs
uh one what is what's his address
uh 140 something
metropolitan or something
metropolitan
122
okay we've already got officers on the
way so just tell me what you see
okay 61 control can you copy 425 a on
metropolitan drive number two
122 metropolitan drive the peer advisor
was a subject walking around asking the
pr for a ride then checking the
neighbor's car door break
she'll continue they're now advising he
is actually inside the pierre's friend's
gray chevy colorado at approximately 122
metropolitan he's going to be a wma very
skinny black and yellow baggy shirt
carrying a bag of empty shell casings
break
control continuing advising that he
appears to be on 446 and he's possibly
wearing black pants brick
control container pier is going to be
watching he's from the corner of linden
and metropolitan and the subjects inside
the
the gray chevy colorado in front of 122
metropolitan drive i'll say you cannot
include
edwards 61 copy and route from taylor
and like me
twenty one controls can you stand by and
be in renaissance
okay
control two edward 61 uh he's going to
be arriving here shortly
advice they're stating he's now getting
in a silver trailblazer and that was in
front of a chevy truck
show me all right
control 261 give us already just ran
eastbound
oh yes code red on main reference the
subject running on the east side code
red on correction info
right he's been in the neighborhood he's
in a backyard i can see him
just be found in the neighborhood in a
backyard
he's at hm he's got a black and yellow
shirt on
objects in hm black and yellow shirt
black hair
shirt black hair saw him in the backyard
of 119 metropolitan he's heading like
north eastbound into the neighborhood
happy last in the backyard of 119
metropolitan
61 is he contained in that backyard
unsure uh it looks like he might be in
101 i don't know what street uh looks
like oh cola
last seen in the backyard of 101 cola by
time we came around to the north side of
the street he didn't pop out so he might
be like a big shed that he was trying to
get into back here
let's start coordinating the incoming
units for containment
i would pick one number 11 you got three
coming from holder in warm springs
okay i'm trying to see if he's hunkered
down we see some movement by a gate back
here to stand by for a second
control if you can see if you can get
fire priors for uh 101 call inside
having to shelter for now
patrol officers arrived in the area and
observed the described mail on
metropolitan drive the male fled from
officers on foot into the backyard of
119 metropolitan and then into the
backyard of 101 cola street
patrol officers were able to contain the
subject at that location
officers provided an update to dispatch
and requested to have residents to
shelter in place
officers then established verbal contact
with the mail and gave him clear
commands from outside the block wall of
101 kohler street the suspect did not
comply and yelled shoot me several times
at the officers while officers continued
verbal commands the male popped his head
over the block wall bringing his right
hand up over the wall and pointed what
appeared to be a firearm at the officers
officers discharged their firearms
striking the suspect several times and
the suspect fell to the ground officers
immediately gained access to the
backyard and began rendering advanced
first aid until paramedics arrived on
the scene the male was transported to
sunrise trauma center at that time
all right he's definitely in this bag
let me see your [ __ ] hand 101
happy subjects in the backyard 101
okay let's get the inconvenience to
contain the backyard for now
you shouldn't repeat your traffic
1933
gunshot wounds to the
stomach possibly chest
and looks like neck currently working
we're going to be good for medical when
you guys get here
control more 52
at this time units are providing medical
aid there's one male down with the gsw
officers are code four
rescued 283's arrived
body-worn video cameras used by the
henderson police department have a
one-minute buffer of video without audio
upon activation the camera goes back one
minute and starts recording this feature
is designed to capture incidents that
occur suddenly where an officer does not
immediately activate the camera the
cameras are worn at chest level by most
officers assigned to field operations
duty and they capture a general
perspective from that angle henderson
officers are required to wear body worn
cameras during operations however
available lighting movement distance and
other factors can affect clarity and
picture quality the following body-worn
camera video is a relevant footage
directly related to the incident i just
described
stand up right now slowly stand up
[Music]
get up
do not [ __ ] reach for anything you
understand what i'm telling you if you
reach for a gun you're gonna get shot do
you understand stand up let me see your
[ __ ] hand
let me see your [ __ ]
you're good you're good you're good
you're good you're good talk
i don't see nobody there
oh he's right here do not [ __ ] move
get up and let me see your hands
hey let me see your [ __ ] hands
keep both your hands where i can see him
do you understand me stand up right now
slowly stand up
get up
do not [ __ ] reach for anything do you
understand what i'm telling you if you
reach for a gun you're going to get shot
do you understand stand up let me see
your [ __ ] hands kill me how does this
[ __ ] hand
get the [ __ ] out
hey he he keeps reaching around
the [ __ ]
shut up
shut fire i was here not the gun
one black crossman p-10 bb gun was
recovered at the scene and booked into
evidence by investigators the bb gun
used by the suspect had a realistic
appearance as seen in the photograph
in the next several months the henderson
police department will continue to
investigate and analyze this incident we
will continue interviewing any new
witnesses that may come forward and
complete forensic tests after the
investigation is complete the findings
will be forwarded to the chief of police
thank you for taking the time to view
this critical incident community
briefing
you